من هذه النقطه التي تفصلنا عن قلب مدينه
او بلده ايلوشكنا خمسه كيلو مترات تفصلنا
عن قلب المدينه كما ان المدينه التي تليها
هي كورسكنا خلفي هنا وسط المدينه وهذا هو
الشارع الرئيسي حيث الاناره ونرى اليافطات
والاشارات اشارات المرور
ولابد من الاشاره الى ان العالقين او
الناجيين او من تم اجلائهم واعدادهم تصل
الى خمسه الاف مواطن قد اصطحبوا امتعتهم
ووثائقهم معهم كما ان اكثر من 60 او 70
مصاب نقلوا الى المشافي رغم حجم الكارثه
الكبير الذي خلفه فيضان نهر دنيبرو بعد
قصف وتدمير سد نوفيكخوفكا اكثر من 20 الف
بيت داخل هذه المنطقه غمرتها المياه
بالكامل الحديث عن ثلاثمائه عالق حتى الان
مفقودون في هذه المنطقه التي غمرتها
المياه بالكامل ايضا الحديث عن قريه اخرى
مجاوره لهذه القريه
الحديث عن مصرع سبعه اشخاص هناك لجان خاصه
من المتطوعين يعملون باستمرار منذ ساعات
الصباح الباكره كما نرى خلفي في الصوره
هناك فان العمليات العسكريه ما زالت
مستمره والقصف المتبادل ما بين الجيشين
الروسي والاوكراني لا يتوقف الكهرباء
مقطوعه بالكامل شبكات الاتصال كلها مقطوعه
لابد من
توثيق هذه الكارثه التي تتزامن مع
العمليات العسكريه التي لا تتوقف وهنا
لابد من الاشاره الى ان قناتي العربيه
والحدث سجلت اول دخول للصحافه العربيه في
منطقه
ووقت هذه المشاهد لقنتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر نوفاك خوفكا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات